>>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOW
WARNING THAT RUSSIA IS PREPARING
TO ANNEX MORE LAND IN UKRAINE,
OFFICIALS SAY THE KREMLIN
FOLLOWING THE PLAYBOOK IT USED
TO TAKE CRIMEA IN 2014.
THEY DO THIS, HOLD SHAM
ELECTIONS, INSTALL PRO KREMLIN
OFFICIALS, FORCE UKRAINIAN
CITIZENS TO THEN APPLY FOR
RUSSIAN CITIZENSHIP.
BUT UKRAINE CONTINUES TO FIGHT
BACK.
OVERNIGHT SHELLING A KEY BRIDGE
THAT RUSSIAN FORCES USE TO
ACCESS KHERSON IN THE SOUTH.
AND JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS,
RETIRED GENERAL PETRAEUS, FORMER
COMMANDER OF U.S. CENTRAL
COMMAND.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME THIS
MORNING.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> SO FIRST YOU FOLLOW THIS WAR
CLOSELY.
I'M CURIOUS WHERE YOU THINK THE
FIGHTING STANDS.
THE RUSSIAN ADVANCE IN THE EAST
APPEARS TO HAVE STOPPED FOR A
BIT OR AT LEAST TAKEN A PAUSE
AND RUSSIA SEEMS TO BE FORCED TO
MOVE FORCES TO THE SOUTH WHERE
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE MAKING SOME
THOUGH INCREMENTAL PROGRESS
AROUND KHERSON WHICH RUSSIA HAS
OCCUPIED SOME FOR TIME.
STOOIM
STILL A FROZEN CONFLICT OR IS
THE MOMENTUM SHIFTING?
>> I THINK THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN DYNAMICS THAT WE CLEARLY
SEE.
AND THEN SOME UNKNOWNS.
THE DYNAMICS WE SEE ARE RUSSIA
HAVING SEIZED THE REST OF
LUHANSK PROVINCE.
AND THEN TAKING A PAUSE.
AS YOU NOTED, THEY NEEDED TO
REPLACE THE LOSSES OF PERSONNEL
AND EQUIPMENT, AMMUNITION AND SO
FORTH.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, THEY HAD
TO MOVE A NUMBER OF THEIR AMMO
STORAGE SITES, THEIR FUEL DEPOTS
AND THEIR HEADQUARTERS OUT OF
RANGE OF THE U.S. AND UK
PROVIDED MULTIPLE LAUNCH ROCKET
SYSTEMS WHICH HAVE HAD A HUGE
IMPACT ESPECIALLY WITH THE
ACCURATE ROCKETS THAT THE U.S.
HAS PROVIDED.
THEY HAVE JUST BEEN -- THEY HAVE
TAKEN OUT WELL OVER A DOZEN OF
THESE DIFFERENT FUEL AMMO AND
HEADQUARTERS LOCATIONS.
AND THEN YOU SEE THE RUSSIANS
NOW LAUNCHING A NEW OFFENSIVE,
BUT IT IS A BIT -- NOWHERE NEAR
THE KIND OF SUBSTANTIAL
OFFENSIVE THAT WE SAW IN
LUHANSK.
THEY ARE NOW TRYING TO SEIZE THE
REST OF DONETSK THE NEIGHBORING
PROVINCE JUST TO THE WEST IN THE
SOUTHEAST OF UKRAINE.
AND WE SEE THE UKRAINIANS
GETTING READY FOR WHAT WE
BELIEVE WILL BE AN OFFENSIVE,
THEY HAVE ANNOUNCED THIS IN
FACT, AN OFFENSIVE TO LIBERATE
THE CITY OF KHERSON JUST NORTH
OF CRIMEA.
AND PERHAPS TO LIBERATE ALL OF
KHERSON OWE BLOSK.
AGAIN, TIME WILL TELL WHETHER OR
NOT THE FORCED GENERATION WITH
THE MASSIVE WEAPONRY THAT WE AND
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE PROVIDED
WILL SUSTAIN THEM IN THIS AND
MAKE THIS CAPABLE FOR THEM.
AND I SHOULD NOTE THAT SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE LLOYD AUSTIN JUST
ANNOUNCED THIS MORNING DURING A
VIRTUAL MEETING OF THE 50
NATIONS SUPPORTING UKRAINE THAT
WE ARE PROVIDING FOUR MORE OF
THE MULTIPLE LAUNCH ROCKET
SYSTEMS WHICH WILL TAKE THAT TO
16, ALSO MORE OF THE PRECISION
AMMUNITION FOR THOSE SYSTEMS AND
FOR THE 155 MILLIMETER HOWITZERS
THAT WE'VE PROVIDED.
SO THAT IS WHAT WE SEE AHEAD.
THIS COULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE UKRAINIANS TO GET ON THE
OFFENSIVE THEMSELVES RATHER THAN
ON THE DEFENSIVE NOTING THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE VERY COSTLY
EXPERIENCE OF GRINDING OFFENSIVE
IN RETAKING ALL OF THAT AREA OF
LUHANSK AND NOW TRYING TO TAKE
AREAS OF DONETSK.
SO IT WILL BE A VERY INTERESTING
SUMMER I THINK.
>> PUTIN HAS MADE A LOT OF
MISTAKES IN THIS WAR INCLUDING
ASSUMING, ONE, THAT UKRAINE WILL
FOLD QUICKLY BUT ALSO THAT NATO
WOULD DISUNITE RATHER THAN UNITE
AS IT HAS DONE.
BUT HE IS ALSO NIMBLE, HE MAKES
CHANGES MIDSTREAM AND NOW HE IS
MEETING WITH BOTH THE TURKISH
AND IRANIAN LEADERS.
WHY DO YOU THINK AND HOW
IMPORTANT IS THAT?
>> WELL, THE REAL OBJECTIVE HERE
OF COURSE IS TO GET IRANIAN
DRONES.
RUSSIANS ARE RUNNING NOW THEIR
OWN DRONES.
WE HAVE EXPERT ROLL, MICROCHIPS
TO RUSSIA, SO THAT MEANS THAT
THEY ARE LIMITED IN WHAT THEY
CAN BUILD IN TERMS OF
REPLACEMENT SYSTEMS INCLUDING IN
UNMANNED AERIAL VEHICLES.
AND THEN HE'D LIKE TO KEEP
TURKEY SOMEWHAT ON SIDE OR AT
LEAST AS NEUTRAL AS TURKEY CAN
BE NOTING THAT IT IS A NATO
MEMBER AND IT HAS BEEN PROVIDING
TURKISH DRONES TO UKRAINE.
SO IS THIS A COMPLICATED
TRIANGULAR DYNAMIC HERE,
DIPLOMACY THAT IS BEING CARRIED
OUT.
AND AGAIN, IT WILL BE VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW MANY
IRANIAN DRONES ARE PROVIDED AND
HOW EFFECTIVE THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ON THE BATTLEFIELD NOTING THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING THEIR
INDIGENOUS DRONE SECTOR FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
>> FINAL QUESTION IF I CAN,
YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE HEARINGS I
KNOW.
AND A KEY WITNESS, PERHAPS ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SO FAR,
MATTHEW POTTINGER, SERVED AS
DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
UNDER TRUMP WILL TAKE THE STAND
AS IT WERE TOMORROW AFTERNOON
REGARDING -- TOMORROW EVENING
RATHER REGARDING THE PRESIDENT'S
ACTIONS OR INACTION ON THE DAY
OF JANUARY 6.
YOU KNOW HIM.
YOU PRESIDED OVER A CEREMONY IN
WHICH HE WAS PROMOTED IN THE
MARINES IN 2016.
HE IS TAKING A RISK HERE.
WE HAVE SEEN HOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS ON THE
RIGHT TREAT THOSE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION AND WHAT
DO YOU THINK THAT HE WILL FACE
AFTER THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, HE IS A VERY
FORTH RIGHT INDIVIDUAL.
HE IS A GREAT MARINE OFFICER.
HE IS STILL IN THE MARINE
RESERVES.
I DID AS YOU NOTED PROMOTE HIM
TO MAJOR IN NEW YORK SOME YEARS
AGO AND HE SERVED IN THE GREATER
CENTRAL COMMAND REGION WHEN I
WAS PRIVILEGED TO COMMAND THAT.
HE WAS IN AFGHANISTAN ON THE
GROUND AT THE TIME.
HE HAS VERY HIGH INTEGRITY, HE
IS A MAN OF CHARACTER, HE WAS
THE DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER AT THE TIME HAVING
EARLIER SERVED AS THE CHINA CZAR
IF YOU WILL.
HE WAS ONE WHO WAS VERY
PROFESSIONAL THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE PERIOD OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TENURE AND HE RESIGNED
IN PROTEST ESSENTIALLY WHEN HE
VIEWED THE FINAL TEXT FROM
PRESIDENT ON THAT DAY.
SO AGAIN, I THINK THAT HE WILL
ACCURATELY LAYOUT WHAT IT WAS
THAT PROMPTED HIM TO RESIGN ON
THAT DAY AND HIS REACTION.
AND I THINK THAT HE WILL THEN
CONTINUE ON WITH HIS LIFE.
HE HAS BUILT A VERY IMPRESSIVE
CONSULTING FIRM HAVING TO DO
WITH ANALYSIS OF CHINA.
>> AND HE WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
THE PRESIDENT'S CHINA POLICY.
AND DAVID PETRAEUS, THANKS FOR
TAKING THE TIME.